breathe it's that time [__]
you
I'm greetings from the Lord's Day uncle
Joey I'm at the Garden of Good and
[__] evil making it happen today it's
the lord's day i'm going to jiu jitsu
good do a little writing a little family
time I'm gonna go down to ebi we got a
podcast later Clark what did I [__]
do it on the Lord's Day you understand
me oh I got this weed this is the last
temptation of christ oh well it comes
with no label and the Russian comes out
of the back room with a [__] gas mask
you know it's gonna be a good goddamn
day for reefer you understand me
tremendous [__] fight last night
congratulate Eddie Bravo and his team of
[__] expert [__] savages coaching
my man tony ferguson over rafael dos
anos you see what happens when the mind
gets involved will sign yours left his
camp he didn't know what was going on
it's never good when you gettin [__]
thoughts into your head from other
places besides that I'm very excited we
got the wool but theatres friday and i
have sold that but if you're in the area
[__] it come on down the foxwoods sunday
night we'll make it happen but uncle
Joey what should the chitter-chatter you
got a spark that number enough is enough
like I told you three four strong dog
we're [__] around on water I give a
[__] what you do during a week on the
Lord's Day you gotta save that but of
death you really get the body started
I'm stall until he kills her I took two
[__] head to this [__] I've been
clean on mon I hate [__] 400
milligrams so that that that [__]
gummy last night I was [__] up
drooling half [__] I love it I love
it when I get to that point i watch the
[__] fights and at some point I must
have [__] passed out understand me I
woke up like a four in the morning white
swan there was a parade in my living
room some guy was selling back pain
medication on TV you know this oh that's
it that's it don't me the city and show
you my famous honey ain't got no friends
I'm solo I show up with a big dick of a
smile that's it show solo [__]
what else you want from me that's it I'm
excited it's gonna be a great [__]
weekend it's gonna be a great week for
you why cuz you got y'all cool Joey
talking to you today is the day where
you sit back and you say to yourself
what do I want from the next [__]
weeks what is the move I need to make to
make my life [__] and go on the board
this is what you take them right now
yeah you're watching football you
[__] friday i got my fantasy coach
here who gives a [__] their life ain't
no [__] fantasy my friend ok so have
you a little [__] fantasy with your
team and then think about mundane pick
up I you're gonna make a [__]
difference in your life this week who
gives a [__] about all this riffraff and
Trump and they're gonna make a
difference in your life dogs you gotta
make it that you gotta get up smoke a
bowl write your goals do 20 push-ups
have a nice [__] arm and smoothly
this reef is gogo be a song what do you
think Oh have I told ya I love it I'll
give a [__] about anything else I don't
need your stupid pills nice but Joey you
might have a deep down give a [__] of it
mom and not being a DBQ my mom in la
piña I don't need pills RV nothing this
is the cure all right here people this
is it this is the cure I ain't no
[__] doctor but you know I'm half
[__] my grandmother married my
[__] second cousin is a grandfather
so somewhere along the line there's
gotta be retardation blind Oleg calling
it oh that's why some of my wreath of me
wkng d dutch station i'm getting gray
and uglier by the day I don't give a
[__] am I little press nobody the only
[__] i got impress is that
[__] in the mirror and as long
as he's happy the rest here to suck my
dick trunk Hillary Bernie Sanders
[__] down you from all of them you
should be picking the same way you don't
trying hey these people now nothing to
do with you in the morning you got to
get up and swing digging at the end of
the day when you're gonna beg your alone
anyway even though that it could be 10
[__] next to you have a little half
of fact 10 year old little boy you still
alone you're alone in this [__]
and you gotta get yourself out of this
[__] situation I didn't I was in a
[__] rocket ship on the third floor
sleeping there whacking off on public at
night put coke rock some of my nose
[__] drinking water from the fountain
get him sample [__] that's behind us
here we are today today oi oi can
MacKinnon come I mamela be no higher
because it's the lord's day ok and
that's it nice that I got [__] to do and
people to see don't forget eight o'clock
tonight Churchill what's happening now
so you've got a monday morning bump it's
ready for you nobody gets their feelings
hurt I love you guys have a great day
with your family I'll see you tonight
for the pre flop in church stay back
stay black stay beautiful and tell them
all to suck it Vickers at the end of the
day it's all a mess